んんん
[音楽]
裸足ランニングトークのキーワードになっていますがかくいう僕も最初は当然シューズ
で走っていました
今話ですけどランニングを始めた理由それはですね
実はあの
お店を始めて10年くらい経った頃からですね
なんとなくどこかへ満たされないなーっ
まあなんかそんな変な感覚になればされ待ってました
え
まあ常連さんもたくさんついてくださってですねえぇまぁお店も経営は順調だったん
ですけど何か満たされない何かがあるなあとまぁそんななんか感情に悩まされていまし
た
まあその理由のつかめないこういう感情ですねなんかあの
まあ何だろうまゆらせるためそんな感じで始めたのがこのランニングだったんですよね
でまぁ
もともとは凝り性だった僕なんですけどまぁなんかその氷商が性格からもあってこの
不安感から逃れるという意味もあってですねこのランディングに自分を追い込むように
何かどんどんどんどん魅了されての巫女になったんです
そしてやっぱりマラソンを走るようにアップになるわけですけど
そして当然ながらやっぱり早く走ってとでまあ僕は3時間聞いたいってもう今日があっ
たんですけどあったそれでどんどんのトレーニングを頭でやっぱり距離をめっちゃ走る
ようなんですけどそしたらですねああ
困ったことにやっぱりケガに悩まされるんだったんですよね
まあこれランナーあるあるなんですけどねでトレーニングをすごい積みたいのにまぁ
走れないで速く走ろうとするとやっぱり
痛みが走るってまあこういう悪循環でそんなフラストレーションを抱えてた時期ですね
あったがある一冊の本だったんです
ボーントゥーランヘ
クリストファーマクドゥーガルという人が書いた本なんですけどまぁ人間は走るために
生まれてきたという
ま内容は思いっきり走りますがまぁその中で僕が一番
心に残った1節というのがですね
人間はそもそも走り裸足で走るようにデザインされているという
まあこの言葉だったんですね
人間も大きなくくりで言えば動物という観点からすればまあ当たり前といえば当たり前
なんですけどまぁランニングって言うまあスポーツですねスポーツっていう観点からは
全く想像ができなかったその裸足ランニング
僕はなんでーそれやってみようと思ったかアーマーそれはですね動物は実は気が
をしないという事実まあ人間も動物だと仮定するのであればですね
まあ裸足で走ったら
ケガをしなくなるんじゃないかば僕はあの怪我に悩んでたので
まあそんな単純な発想からでしたそしたらどうなったか
めちゃめちゃ痛かったですん
2本取りほんとありえないと思いましたでそれまでですねほんとになる20キロ30
キロ中だった走ってたのがですね
もう2キロぐらいでももう痛すぎて無理みたいなまぁただですね
朴正体育会系っていうのはあったんですけどまぁ本にできる人がいると書いてあると
じゃあ俺にもでいいんだろうともうなんかもしつこくやり続けたんですよね少しずつ
距離を伸ばせてそしたらですね
いろんなことがわかったんです
足の裏というのは素晴らしいセンサーだということがわかったんですね
まあなんでかっていうとこれはまあ皆さん実感していただけると思うんですけどまぁ
あの靴の中でちょっとした行為し入っただけでもすごいなんか煩わし
中で
すごいやっぱり感じますよねまぁそれぐらいすぐの繊細なセンサーだと
まあその脚ランセンサーをですね最大限に使って
まああの裸足で走るわけですよそうするとですねその自分の走りや痛みやっぱり少ない
ように
まぁなんだそのセンサーから情報ですね受け取って
で衝撃やっぱりなるべく少なくするようにそしてもっとしなやかな
始めるまぁそうやって自分の走りをどんどんどんどん変えていったんですまあ洗練させ
ていって言ったというかね
まっしかもですねまぁ当たりましてコーチの指導もなしえ
そうです
足裏って言うのはねあの素晴らしいセンサーであると同時にですねまぁ先生でもあった
ということですね
裸足で走り始めたらですねえ
不思議なことにあーれー報道を悩まされていた男性的な気がそれからほぼ無縁になった
んですよね
いやまぁ足裏やっぱりまだちょっと痛かったんですけどまぁそれもやっぱり裸足の走り
がどんどん洗練されていってですね
まあそうしたらもう痛みもほぼなくなってったんですよね
ねえ
そして
さらに一番大きく変わった事実というのは
いることが頭に一角楽しくなったんですよ
シューズを履いて走っている時もまあそれはそれで楽しかったんですけど
まあそれは
楽しいまあ楽しみでありリシン目の楽しみではなかったと
まああのらくの方の楽しみっていうのはそのあの
文字通りイージーな喜びというかですねまあシューズで走って速さを求めて他人と競っ
てまぁ自分と競ってですね
他により優っていうことはやっぱりあの追求するような走りだったんですね
であのリシべの楽しむ裸足で走るということでそれは自分もない女
内面にフォーカスした喜びそこにやっぱり4化するようになったと
まあ走ること自体の本質的な喜び
誰かと競うのではなくその走るっていうこと自体をですね全身全霊をかけて楽しむよう
な感覚
そういうふうに変わったんです
シューズを履いて走っている時っていうのですねまあやっぱりトレーニングてば辛い
わけですよね
まあそれ圧迫痛だったんですよ
ですけどですね裸足で走るようになってはですね
そもそもそのトレーニングという大ね時代はもうなくなちゃいます
なぜならばというと走ること自体が喜びであって走ることのすべてが喜び
そういうふうに変わったわけですよね
まあいうラバー裸足になることですね
自分の中に眠っていた関西
まあそれをやっぱり取り戻すことができてですね物事の
音質的な部分それを楽しめるようになった
まあそう言ってもいいかもしれないです
最初のお話した通りですねあの表現しがたいすごいながその満たされない仕事に対して
感情というがあると言いますよね
まああのそれがあったわけですよ実はですねその裸足で走るようになってからその何か
満たされないなーっていう思う思いっていうのはですねまあ一つの答えみたいなものは
何か出てきたんですよ
まあそれが何なのかというとまあ自分は
シューズというまあものとせるものとせのシューズ
それに依存してたようにお酒お酒を童ものとして捉えてその者としてのお酒に依存せた
んだなと
そういうことがすごいやっぱなんか自分の中に何かそうなのかなって思い始めたんです
よね
えっ
それまでですねまぁ何かに取り憑かれたようにですねあの珍しいお酒をまあ
どんどんどんどん多い求めて
まあお酒を楽しむというよりは何かを避けを収集するかのようにですね
まあ飲んだことないものみまー片っ端から飲んでですね
でまぁ減らし評価するときも桜花お酒のまあ
粗を探すまあここがちょっとバランス悪いよねとか
まあそういうような感じで
なんかお酒と付き合ってですねでまぁどれだけものすごいものを揃えてるか
まあ何だろうそういうことで他の店と差別化を図るような世界ですかね
まあそういう世界観で何か仕事をしてたんですよね
でもですねそれがあの裸足ランディングが僕に与えた
え
自分自身の主観的な完成まあそれを取り戻して物事を本質的に楽しむ
まあそういう気づきを与えてくれるわけですけどまあそういう風になってから
まあお酒っていうもの時代ではなくですねそのものにたため煮込まれているストーリー
そういう本質にやっぱり方か
すー
させてくるようになったわけです
でまぁ僕はあのシューズをまーぬ犠牲たようにですね
まぁ今まで持ってた知識とか経験まあそれを目に見える誰もが知ることができるもの
ですよねそういうの1回ちょっと
hers してみて
まあお酒のその畳み込まれているその
裏の歴史であったりとか
まあ作っている人の思いであったりとか
まぁあとはあのそれを楽しんできた人たちの
まあ喜びの記憶まあそんなもんですねそういうものに大勢ちょっとあの
フォーカスするようになったんですよね
そしてやっぱりはバーテンダーとしてのお酒との向き合い方もやっぱり変わってきまし
た
お酒というのはへ
まあそのを下げの裏というかまぁそのあるですねそこに幾重にも重なってばストーリー
がある訳ですけどそれを
結局楽しむための一つの道具に過ぎないと
そういうふうにやっぱりそのバーテンダーとしてのお酒の付き合い方も変わってきまし
た
でバーテンダーは結局最初はですね僕はものをお酒をただ売る人みたいな感じで
やっぱり取られてるわけですけどそこからそうではなくてお酒の裏に畳壊れている
いろんなストーリー舌ようですねまぁ伝える人間だと
岩ストーリーテラーまあそういうふうにあの
自分のことがまあバーテンダーとしてそういうふうに思ってまあそれがやっぱり風に
落ちてきたわけですね
そしてですねまあなんかあのそれまで何かす自分の中の何かをすり減らすように仕事を
せた
まあそういう自分とは全く違う自分なんか生まれ変わったんですよ
さあどういうふうに変わったかというと
お酒というもの自体を心から楽しめるようになってそのお酒の場
バージトゥ
10号やっぱり大切にするようになってそしてそのバーテンダーという職業
それに携われたっていうことに対して本
頭に心から感謝感謝できるようになったんですよ
あーやっぱバーテンダーっておりの天職じゃんって
そう訪問やだったんですよね
でここでへ
僕はみなさんにちょっと提案歳です
まずはですねあなたの内なる完成
それを妨げるシューズ
それをいかに脱ぎせてもらえたんです
そして自身にちょっと遠いかけてみてほしいんですよね
シューズが足裏がやっぱり感覚を麻痺させて
いたようですねー
英語だったりとか世の中で常識
言われているようなこと
まあそれがそういう観念がですね自分の感覚を鈍らせてるんじゃないかっ
で自分の命の前にある世界それをありのままに先入観とか固定観念とか全部なしに
捉えることができているのかと
誰かがいいって言ってるとかこれは常識的に正しいとかそれは本当に自分が感じたまま
なんですかと
それでひょっとして他人のなんか評価が刷り込まれていたりとかですね
他人と比べることによってその評価が影響されたりしてないですか
まぁまずは自分自身が感じていることですそれを先入観なしに
自身が持っているものすべてを使って味わい尽くしてみてほしいと
他人がどう感じようと他人がどう言われようとそういうのは
本当の自分の中の内なる感性に対して影響を与えるべきものではないのではないかと
自分が好きなものは好きだと
そもそもそれに対する理由を考えなくてもいいんじゃないかと
大雪などは何でそれが好きかって言う理由よりもですね
自分のその内なる関西からクルー
好きだーっていう
気持ち
それに対して素直になることを素直であること
でまぁもちろんですよそのやっぱり自分の感性の赴くままに自分自身の行動をやっぱり
変えていったら
やっぱりあのそれまでの自分というのはやっぱりその辺がやっぱりびっくりするし
戸惑うし時にはやっぱりいってーなーっ
思うこともあるかもしれないです
ではですねちょっと待って欲しいのはいたいからっつってすぐに辞めないで欲しいです
よね
その痛みの奥にはね
やっぱり
本当は隠れてて感じることができない自分の奥底の何かっていうのがやっぱりあると
思うんですよねそれをやっぱり探してみてほしいです
それはですやっぱり最初は本当に感じる事で一つほんっとにも微細な感覚かもしれない
です
まあでも必ずあなたの内なる感性というのはあなたに対してやっぱり何かしらの信号を
送ってくれてるはずなんですよ
僕はその信号を
まあその微細な感覚をですよねとにかく大事にしてほしいですよ
蘇生ですね
もう一つ大事にしてもらえよ
痛みとはネガティブなものではないということです
まあそして我慢するものでもないということ
まあそれはある意味は本当のあなたがはのメッセージ
メッセージますよ
であなたが心から楽しいと
覚えてありのままの自分で
いられる自分そういう自分へ導いてってくれるアラートみたいなもん
そしてもう一ス痛みとは気づき
僕が足裏の痛み最初痛かったんですがそれを受け入れてですね
その気づきから自分のランニングをどんどんどんどん洗練させていったようにですね
シューズみたいなものに頼って自分のまわりの世界を変えようとするのではなく痛みの
メッセージを頼りにまあを受け取ってですね
自分自身を変えて行ってみたよ欲しいんですよね
そうすれば気づくと思うんです
今まで自分が見ていた世界がいかに一元的なものであったのかということ
生まれ変わったですねあなたの目の前に広がる世界
それはですね
生きること自体が喜びであって
生きることのすべても喜びであって
でそんな本当に喜びに満ち溢れた
って物事をあらゆる側面から先入観とかなしに味わい尽くせる
そんな世界があるって僕は信じています
本日はここまでご清聴ください本当にありがとうございました
あなたの人生が a
あなたにしか歩むことができない素晴らしいものでなることを心から望んでいます
蜂場でさとは5打差
[拍手]